what are the things that i need to keep
doing day in day out that hopefully
would mean over a period of time it will
really start paying off yeah i think we
had a chat about this i think it's about
short-term media and term long-term so
the short term is the jobs on your table
and that's what people typically just
tend to look at and tend to work yeah
you've got to start thinking about the
median term which is okay how do i those
clients i'm working with how do i get
into them more how do i expand them and
in long term the clients you don't even
know yet what am i doing around that so
am i putting out
my brand what are people recognizing
what i'm the best at what i'm saying i'm
the best at least am i making creating
events am i posting things on social
media so i think it's just down to the
planning which is don't just look at
what's on your desk right now think
about what's going to be on your desk in
a couple of months time and i like that
because it's so easy to look at just
what's in front of you we phrased it as
the fight the battle and the war fight
battle of war you need all of them
[Music]